welcome to this 15-minute game into this
video okay on what do we have here
Victoire 24 down Romania Romania too
tough to say on left side good up in
Belgium ok we have a closer soliant
Grand Prix attack and chef i'm not
mistaken i need to do this here oh it's
been ages that i am look at this opening
yeah i think it's the capture and then
d5 takes a night of six now a six and
then Knight f6 yeah I know this this has
been recommended by Roman gentius really
one of his thousands of dvds or whatever
I never could believe that this should
be anything great for white but it's an
interesting I think I take here now and
term yeah it's the straights put the
strange position where I take on c3 not
much choice anyway Jack okay so white
that's one upon but I have firm
I have the bishop pal and you've got the
compromised structure and okay question
is so what to do the poor not be serving
as a possible weakness and also now he's
got the night g 595 type of moves I
could take here but it really
accelerates the development yeah I
wonder maybe Bishop tutu d 726 yeah the
problem is once he plays a move like 95
I have a hard time not to take it
yeah its difficulty obviously knows what
what the theoretical status of this is
playing very quickly and i don't i don't
know it like bishop design hm it's
difficult look be one Bishop see 695 it
really already must take them it's not
great
okay let's let's consider why do I put
the King King to see Sutton Place always
got this noisy for business
ok then i'm going to prevent this night
g5 stuff and then planning king c7 and
Bishop f5 or Bishop e6 if he goes no ID
for I have ok yeah let's just go here a
good place for the King I guess yeah
that's um it's not it's white like it's
not so well coordinated it's a matter of
getting getting enough time if you get
some time here like e6 Bishop d7 Bishop
c6 black is starting to feel comfortable
but it's not so clear if I I will manage
that and he's got those moves like ma'am
like c6 like jettison upon and try to
use the beef farm and maybe night the
night moves and Bishop deform yeah this
is this is a good plan really maybe
thought that a bit late maybe Bishop d7
wasn't really good enough to address
this idea that's a good planner but if
the night moves to any place like f 30 b
3 I must take C 3 ok
yeah to see does he threaten anything
like c6 Bishop takes Knight ex King
takes rook b6 check maybe but on c6 I
have possibly Bishop takes d4 IM if the
rook has almost
where to go
uncie 6 i'm going to check you for so
that's not really threatening yeah it's
some kind comfortable to play a really
so this initiative the Dwight has
something
I'm not quite sure what what what is
doing now yeah what's my plan here
rookie a term yeah maybe yeah it's
completely unrealistic at the moon move
lucky five breaking up the position but
it's not possible at all at the moment I
just got this the c6 month I wonder
maybe the rook d8 bishop CA door
something
yeah the funniest thing is that
interesting move the funny thing is what
daughter was trying to say is that if I
get some stuff exchange I start to have
a good position but it's a it's a it's
some dangerous initiative
just Ruby one coming it's not
comfortable at all
and he's got c6 all the time
so hard to play without that poor not
great it really isn't yeah just should
be one name of quite sure what I'm doing
against that well even if he gets to
play that I'm not quite sure that white
is threatening something really yeah
that's that's another possibility very
direct play the ship deform there should
be fine Bishop deform Bishop f5 this
Bishop b5 check coming yeah so I
probably have to take that I could play
g5 maybe g5 now but he possibly can play
something like Bishop f-22 g3 year that
sets that's quite quite a problem
okay if I take with the pawn now just
night takes probably cakes rook takes
champ it's not that it's not great
very very tricky position to take it
yeah it's really ugly stuff maybe yeah I
don't know it just looks like a bad
position
just neither five is good for white I
think I feel night a hyphen chan okay
maybe i can i can take e 59 f seven and
then f 6m that's so ugly but maybe I can
play that yeah I don't think that Bishop
takes h6 is so great I can exchange on
age six and play e-cigs probably this
shouldn't be so so awful just neither
five takes bishop c3 Bishop f4 check 85
not very attractive but maybe I must do
that if you consider neither five Bishop
f5 look at five there's all kinds of
stuff hanging
yeah just night age six probably
the only real Jack perspective here now
five is at least I can play that
currently at least yeah here I actually
thought I could take and give this check
to take c5 now let's still a crappy
position it still is he will get that
born
I give this check here 96 season as a
move that is probably just around the
corner maybe York g8 try try to do
something with with the g-tube on Bishop
c6 this kind of stuff now yeah it's
probably why it probably has some
something-something excellent hearing it
looks very very shaky this position not
not sure what exactly 93 maybe a 97
rather 95 okay but I have that after the
intermediate check er you before yeah
yeah I don't know I have a bad feeling
about it but maybe it's okay i have this
check here check now i can even take on
on b6 it's got 95 check but is this a
problem
95 key 8 one point is I mean it's not a
material issue I mean I was upon down
but this was just this CC porn the
problem is the coordination and if I'm
not instantly suffering material losses
I'm not such bad such bad shape nigeria
b6 shouldn't be too bad i think it is
attacked and i have bishop e6 coming
probably i can get a chance check here
now here or here yeah okay time is
limited so when I got I got one power
back and maybe I get the bishop to c6
this would be excellent of course aiming
it towards the g2 pond
hey it's got c4 Sophie yeah I don't know
where a is good I also can just go
Bishop e6 next myth I've still be within
a move like rook d8 can be can be
problematic I mean if you move the rock
and I play whatever then look do you
want my king is still in a man in a bit
of a bit of a bit of a tight spot maybe
with Bishop e3 I can a bishop before I
can do things let's say bishop let's say
rook could be three bishops e6 rook d3
then Bishop deform actually at exit this
might be something my is taking some
time at least don't don't know it's a
very tricky I don't I had this this was
the toughest move which I which I
vaguely saw when I thought the way I
couldn't really believe that he is going
for it okay if I go Bishop g4 what
assistance he does not have her
he does not have what is exactly the
problem I do that I'm not seeing it no I
can take you 1 and b six legs and if he
moves the rock i will take b6 him ok you
can I don't get it let's let's see what
happens I think I'm just winning an
exchange now but maybe I'm overlooking
something I mean all my pieces are
uncovered I mean lots not not protected
I mean so I might overlook some some
tactical shot
he moves let's say rook d three amber
should be 696 checking seven I don't I
don't really maybe okay I need to take
it any check or here but have king is
seven now ok you might go to d5 or
should I go to see seven maybe maybe
easier but 95 yeah okay this should be
ok check yeah this is just a piece right
while the tough defense and white
certainly certainly had a good position
ok meet went to d2 so we cannot even
coverage e to check ok to you can go to
d2 ok yeah but besides the fact that
it's a piece i'm also having an attack
him I could have taken the rook I could
have just taken the rook ok but it does
not happen it does not have a great
square available
can just win it technically check
checkmate yeah we have a self meet but
okay it didn't really matter at the end
that was a really bad position I think
analysis will show that that white was
an excellent and excellent shape yeah I
know that this is a theoretical position
but I don't really know how it is played
I mean this is maybe not not correct I
don't know I can I can pull up I can
pull this up oops sorry for all this I
can I can do this which I normally don't
do but then i can i can ask my database
let me just enter it oops i need to put
it on the board Queen da I'm curious
what is the right move here ok h 6 s
normal th not a good one probably black
takes on c3 seems to be the best move
yes yeah it probably one reason is not
the pawn but it's also this spot on g4
that the porn controls okay so um let's
see I mean maybe this wasn't the best
possible way to play but it shouldn't be
totally terrible yeah but it looks it
looks it looks really iffy why it has
some substantial pressure
and I don't really have any play so that
the saw looked very very very strong not
much choice i mean this looked check
find here i'm not sure about that that's
not clear to me you can also just take
here yeah difficult I intended to play
this and then yeah try to hold on major
this check here after 85 just back and
how do i do I cover that yeah why does a
very very good shape maybe winning check
I don't channel or maybe this was okay
as well here where rocky 6 is also a
possibility so this is maybe a mistake I
don't I don't know yeah the computer
wants to play rugby three yeah that's
strong just a strong move I wanted to
take but this is also good for white is
got that one yeah that's just a good end
game he's got this pic activity the
spawn is hanging it's very good for
white guy rock b3 seems very strong and
this is probably a mistake I mean here
I'm getting the palm and now it's a
double attack probably just play that
and I think this is losing due to Bishop
g4 ideas he needs to retreat and play
something like that this is something
that white can still fight on this
position it's I got the bishops but he's
got this play the computer wants to do
that just to show why black is
in good shape after all I can use the
king to put pressure on the pole and
have f6 to cover it my king which was a
liability is now an assets because it
plays in the end game and he does not
have an attack really yeah that's pretty
good for black yeah this 97 really
really gave it away and ta be sure
before is winning for black check check
Jim just I'm just a born up air and the
piece up sorry and winning this is a
tricky opening for black obviously he's
under this initial pressure and very
difficult to play with limited time
alright thanks for watching